welcome to Hannity and tonight after two
leisurely vacations your President Joe
Biden well he finally found time to stop
by Maui for a very quick trip knowing
the devastation it's unreal now
unfortunately Joe is only staying for a
couple of hours before then heading back
to Lake Tahoe to continue his latest
luxurious getaway Joe has reportedly now
taken more time off than any other
president in the history of the country
over a thousand by the way people are
still missing in Maui what took him so
long if this was Donald Trump if this
was George W bush you can bet the medium
mob would be comparing this rightly so
to Katrina etc etc now by the way dozens
uh maybe hundreds of children also part
of that group of missing people Biden's
vacation that's the top priority for
them tonight and of course the president
the first lady they're not vacationally
vacationing alone per usual Hunter of
course is tagging along it's free
despite several new bombshell reports
from mainstream media Outlets we'll get
to this in a second alleging serious
misconduct involving Joe Hunter the doj
and specifically David Weiss now
according to the Washington Post the
special counsel investigating Hunter
Biden had close ties with Hunter Biden's
late brother Bo the son of Joe Biden a
quote worked with Joe Biden's eldest son
to hash out prosecution strategies when
Bo was the Attorney General of Delaware
and as the post points out quote
although Democrats point to Weiss's
appointment by President Donald Trump as
evidence of his independence oh the full
story of his career is far more nuanced
in other words Weiss is probably a probe
Biden prosecutor he previously spent two
years as acting U.S attorney under
President Obama and then Vice President
Joe Biden and then quote retain remained
as a deputy for the remainder of their
term and according to the New York Times
after purposely allowing the statute of
limitations to expire on several serious
significant felonies regarding Hunter
Biden Weiss Was preparing to wrap up
that five-year Hunter Biden
investigation we now know thanks to the
New York Times without any charges at
all whatsoever quote Mr Weiss appeared
willing to forego any prosecution of Mr
Biden at all in his office came close to
agreeing to end the investigation
without requiring any guilty plea on any
charges even though Weiss's own office
reportedly recommended felony charges
against Hunter Biden so the sweetheart
deal only came into play when two Brave
IRS whistleblowers came forward alleging
this misconduct that sweetheart deal was
basically Weiss's Plan B in other words
the second attempt to sweep everything
under the rug a deal that also included
an offer buried in the the gun deferment
aspect of the agreement against immunity
offered me Community against any further
charges and was only stopped by a brave
federal judge in Delaware that rejected
it and raised questions about it
needless to say Hunter's legal team is
furious this was supposed to be water
under the bridge they first expected no
charges then that sweetest of sweetheart
slap on the wrist deal that they had
evolving into the next uh Plan B and now
based on reporting we know tonight from
The New York Times Hunter Biden's
lawyers they were lobbying Joe Biden's
Department of Justice to prosecute the
whistleblowers from even coming forward
and now this needs to be investigated
team Biden now wants these government
whistleblowers locked up what out of
pure Vengeance and what is being called
the chilling threat it is now please
don't expect Vice President Biden to
voice any concern for them he only
revered whistleblowers only when they
had bad things to say about Donald Trump
let's take a trip down memory lane shall
we
we not only know about this thanks to
the courageous actions of a
whistleblower
who has since been joined by others
stepping up to protect our country
Trump's scheme has been exposed and now
allegedly I don't know for a fact the
whistleblowers are worried about their
safety
thanks to our president
trump it is shameful
he has no shame though
well Joe you have no shame because that
was a hearsay whistleblower uh so what
happened to Joe Biden Biden never cared
about whistleblowers he just wanted to
smear Donald Trump and now he's
desperately wanting to protect the Biden
brand which by the way is not Hunter
Biden in fact the Biden brand is Joe
Biden no one in Biden's orbit really
cares if Hunter Biden even goes to
prison frankly except probably Joe
they're worried about the implications
for that guy the big guy the guy that's
running for re-election in fact
according to Politico Hunter Biden's own
attorneys they warned Joe Biden's doj
that they would put the president on the
stand during a future trial in a pretty
threatening 32-page letter an attorney
representing Hunter Biden wrote this
this of all cases justifies neither the
spectacle of a sitting president
testifying at a criminal trial nor the
potential for a resulting constitutional
crisis on his lawyer complaining that
such a case would pit the Press
president himself against his very own
Department of Justice wait a minute I
thought the justice department I thought
they were supposed to be independent
isn't Justice in America supposed to be
blind equal application of our laws
equal justice under the law guess how
naive of me in these times because now
we're on to plan C for Weiss which is
yet another run out the clock operation
now as special counsel protecting
himself against allegations against The
Whistleblower and his boss the guy that
appointed a Merrick Garland so don't
expect him to act like Donald Trump's
special counsel expect him to mimic Joe
Biden's special counsel in the top
secret document case has anyone ever
heard or seen Robert Herr hello all
points bulletin if anyone has seen or
heard from that special prosecutor
please let us know what while the doj
continues to Shield Joe Biden the mob
the media well they're starting to turn
and this is an interesting moment look
at where all these recent reports have
come from The Washington Post the New
York Times Politico hardly conservative
organizations matter of fact they lied
to this country for three long years in
the case of the New York Times
Washington post about Russia collusion
that never happened they lied they
spread conspiracy theories day after day
year after year and perhaps maybe the
canary in the coal mine maybe is
actually Maureen dowd's piece that was
criticizing Joe Biden for his disgusting
treatment of his seventh grandchild that
he refused to even acknowledge Joe
Biden's lack of basic human decency and
allege is now impossible to ignore even
among Biden's biggest apologists even on
msdnc this could be this could be a
movement this could be the beginning of
dominoes beginning to fall saying you
know what Joe Biden is not up to the job
we need to replace him I don't know just
think about it as you watch this current
position that President Biden is taking
on this his public position is not
sustainable his son will probably be on
trial there's every possibility he'll be
on trial during this campaign staff
can't even get to the president about
the issue because they don't want to
address a sensitive topic with the
president they've got to challenge it
this stuff has taken a huge toll on him
you know Biden right before the 2020
election he was right side up which in
our polarized politics is quite
astonishing but look Trump and Rudy
gilani began this campaign to try to
tarnish Biden to try to turn him into
the Clinton name you know with the with
the obsession over over the Ukraine
businesses with Hunter and its work his
numbers now look more like Hillary
Clinton 16 then Biden 20
now Joe does not have a good answer
about his involvement in his son's
business deals because he's been
constantly repeatedly caught lying about
them as evidence comes out you know that
lie now continues to evolve remember
first never once did I ever speak to my
son hunter or my brother or anybody from
that for that matter regarding their
foreign business dealings let alone in
let alone interacted with any of
Hunter's business partners then the
story had to change after Devin Archer
came out well Joe was never in business
with his son hunter or brother or any of
their Farm business partners and now
that has evolved into the truth which is
coming out and that is that Joe Biden
met with Hunter's partners and talked to
them on the phone but they never
discussed business they only had
conversations about the weather are you
kidding me now some are admitting the
obvious and conceding that the big guy
did have some kind of role in Hunter's
business deals but as one former White
House deputy director proudly quoted
well the comer Mo doesn't show direct
payment no but it's on Hunter's laptop
half his income to Pops ten percent for
the big guy you know emails with Hunter
and error Eric Sherwin saying oh here
are the bills for for Dad's uh homes how
much what account should I pay it from
you see the foreign money went to Hunter
and other Biden family members James
Comer says nine so then it got to Joe in
the form that Hunter mentioned the
American people are not buying this
latest lie and now some of the media mob
they're slowly beginning to try and
catch up to us it'll take them a while
uh seeing that maybe the handwriting is
on the wall maybe these dominoes are
about to fall and breaking tonight
according to documents obtained by
investigative reporter editor-in-chief
of just thenews.com John Solomon Biden's
actions in Ukraine as vice president
leveraging one billion of your taxpayer
dollars to force out Ukraine's top
prosecutor it may not have even been in
line with U.S policy at the time in
other words this brand new evidence and
suggesting Joe Biden got a Ukrainian
prosecutor fired in spite of American
policy not for the benefit of the U.S
not following U.S policy but for another
reason like protecting his son that so
his son can continue to be enriched at a
time when he's addicted to drugs and at
a time when he's admitting he had no
experience in oil energy gas whatsoever
or Ukraine Paris maholdings they were
under investigation by the very same
prosecutor that Joe insisted be fired in
six hours and remember a trusted FBI
Source accused barisma giving Joe and
Hunter that 5 million dollar bribe each
five for one Biden five for another and
it'll take you 10 years to figure out
how I paid it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else